welcome back to the show facebook.com
slash david pakman show please give us a
like on facebook heading towards 100,000
likes there let's go back to the phones
617 830 4750 let's go to a caller from
the 802 area code I believe 802 is our
friendly neighbors to the north not
Canada but Vermont I think okay caller
from 80 to what's your name and where
you're calling from yeah this is
christian from northern Vermont awesome
what's on your mind so I wanted to ask
you guys about the systems of primary
elections at different states use okay
so what's your opinion on these like I
know different states have closed and
open in the some allow independents and
some don't like here in Vermont we have
full open primaries and I'm not sure
what you have in Massachusetts but like
what's your opinion on independence and
the idea that other voters from other
parties could sort of infiltrate another
primary and vote for a candidate that's
against for that party against that
party's views or write something along
those lines okay so generally number one
in Massachusetts I am I'm independent or
in Massachusetts it's called unenrolled
your night heart of either party so on
election day I can choose to either
Vaughn primary days I can go and they'll
ask me do I want a democratic ballot or
a Republican ballot for a primary and I
can choose I'm completely in favor of
that there's another level though Pat
which is the idea that regardless of
party registration even if you're a
Democrat or Republican by registration
that you should still be allowed to show
up and vote in whichever primary you
want to I have not seen a compelling
argument to allow that in the sense that
if really you are a Democrat you have
decided that although you could be
independent you have decided that you
want to have an allegiance to one
particular party and thus there's a case
to be made that you shouldn't be able to
go up and rather than then vote in the
primary of the party you remember a boat
in a different party uh if you're just
for sort of like hey everybody can do
whatever they want they can vote one
pick the primary doesn't matter then you
could say well now you should be allowed
to vote wherever but I've not beyond
that I've not seen a compelling argument
for Democrats to vote in a Republican
primary yeah I get that because it kind
of allows you to spoil the other party's
process and some people feel like well
this is our party we get to have a
choice as to who gets to vote
Massachusetts it is technically an open
primary but with exceptions because
while if you're unaffiliated you can
choose either ballot if you're a
Democrat you have to go to our
democratic primary Republican
Republicans yep so yeah one of those
things that letter by a big deal because
a lot of these states that people voted
in didn't have open primaries and
because a lot of people were
independents or even some Republicans
who would want to support him were
disenfranchised that allowed Hillary to
win ultimately and get the nomination
you know what I'm more concerned with it
would be great to be able to register
the day of the primary right I think
that that is something which not all
states have which would have a much more
democratic impact and of course as we
know the higher voter turnout is it
tends to favor the more progressive
candidate so I think that that's a big
deal yeah I just want to get your
opinions on that I don't hurt a
semi-open primary just because I feel
like independent should be able to vote
for different parties but I don't think
that party-affiliated people should be
able to go across the aisle and put in
other parties so thanks for taking my
call alright pleasure a very very good
question and really appreciate the call
from Vermont I'm a fan of Vermont I drew
up through and I've done skiing you know
twice or something